let's say I have some curve see and it's
described it can be parametric
parametric eyes I can't say that word as
let's say X is equal to X of T y is
equal to some function y of T and let's
say that this is valid for T is between
a and B so T is greater than or equal to
a and then less than or equal to B so if
I were to just draw this on hey let me
see I could draw it like this
I'm staying very abstract right now this
is not a very specific example this is
the x axis this is the y axis my curve
let's say this is when T is equal to a
and then the curve might do something
might do something like this I don't
know what it does let's say it's over
there this is T is equal to B this
actual point right here will be X of B
that would be the x coordinate you
evaluate this function at B and Y of B
and this is of course when T is equal to
a the actual coordinate in r2 on this
and the Cartesian coordinates will be X
of a which is this right here and then Y
of a which is that right there and we've
seen that before that's just a standard
way of describing a parametric equation
or curve using two parametric equations
what I want to do now is describe to
this same exact curve using a vector
valued function so if I define a vector
valued function and if you don't
remember what those are we'll have a
little bit of a review here let me say I
have a vector valued function R and I'll
put a little vector arrow on top of it
in a lot of textbooks they'll just bold
it and they'll leave scalar valued
functions unfolded but it's hard to draw
a bolt so I'll put a little vector on
top and let's say that R is a function
of T and these are going to be position
vectors position vectors position
position vectors I'm specifying that
because in general when someone talks
about a vector this vector and
this vector are considered equivalent as
long as they have the same magnitude and
direction no one really cares about what
their start and end points are as long
as their directions the same and their
length is the same but when you talk
about position vectors you're saying no
these vectors are all going to start at
zero at the origin and when you say it's
a position vector you're implicitly
saying this is specifying a unique
position in this case is going to be in
two dimensional space but it could be in
three-dimensional space or really even
four or five whatever n-dimensional
space so when you say it's a position
vector you're literally saying okay this
vector literally specifies that point in
space so let's let's see if we can
describe this curve as a vector a
position vector valued function so we
could say R of T let me switch back to
that pink color well this K in green is
equal to X of T times the unit vector in
the X Direction the unit vector gets a
little carrot on top a little hat that's
like the arrow for it that just says
it's a unit vector plus y of T y of T
times J if I had if I was dealing with a
curve in three dimensions that would
have plus Z of T times K but we're
dealing with two dimensions right here
and so the way this works is you're just
taking your well for any T and you know
and still we're going to have T is T is
greater than or equal to a and then less
than or equal to B and this is the exact
same thing as that let me just redraw it
so let me draw our coordinates our
coordinates right here our axes so
that's the y-axis and this is the x-axis
so when you evaluate R of a right that's
our starting point so let me do that so
R of a maybe I'll do it right over here
our position vector valued function
evaluated at T is equal to a is going to
be equal to X of a times our unit vector
in the X Direction plus y of a times our
unit vector in the vertical direction or
in the Y direction and what's that going
to look like well X of a let's go X of a
is this thing right here so it's X of a
times the unit vector
so it's really you know maybe the unit
vector is this long it has length one so
now we're just going to have a length of
X of a in that direction and then same
thing in Y of a it's going to be Y of a
length in that direction but the bottom
line this vector right here if you add
these scaled values of these two unit
vectors you're going to get you're going
to get R of a looking something like
this it's going to be a vector that
looks something like that
just like that it's a vector it's a
position vector that's why we're
kneeling it at the origin but drawing it
in standard position and that right
there is our of a now what happens if a
increases a little bit what is R of a
plus a little bit and I don't know we
could call that R of a plus Delta R of a
plus h we do it in different colors so
let's say R let's say we increase a a
little bit R of a plus some small H well
that's just going to be X of a plus h
times the unit vector I plus y times a
plus h times the unit vector J and
what's that going to look like well
we're going to go a little bit further
down the curve that's like saying the
coordinate X of a plus h and y plus a
plus h éeer it might be that point right
there so we will go to it'll be a new
unit vector it'll be a u a new unit
vector sorry it'll be a new vector
position vector not a unit vector these
are don't necessarily have length one
that might be right here let me do that
same color as this so there might be
just like just like that
so that right here is R of a plus h so
you see as you keep increasing your
value of T until you get to be these
these position vectors are going to keep
specifying we're going to keep
specifying points along this curve so
the curve let me draw the curve in a
different color the curve looks
something like this
it's meant to look exactly like the
curve that I have up here and for
example R of B is going to be is going
to be a vector that looks like this it's
going to be a vector that looks like
that let me I want to draw it relatively
straight that vector right there is R
our of be so hopeful you realize that
look these position vectors really are
specifying the same points on this curve
as this original I guess straight up
parametrizations that we did for this
curve and I just want to do that as a
little bit of review because we're not
going to break in into the idea of
actually taking a derivative of this
vector valued function and I'll do that
in the next video